hi i'm kevin and this is my first drink
of the night
i'm joe and i think drunk will be the
most nick tonight hey i'm joe this is my
uh first drink of the night
now i can
it's joe jonas's birthday and he can
take shots and sing kelly clarkson's
songs if he wants to it's going to be a
party and that it was as the singer rang
in his 33rd birthday alongside brothers
nick and kevin and a few pals joe gave
fans a glimpse of his bash on tick tock
with the guys taking bets on who'd get
the drunkest that night
i'm joe and i think drunk will be the
most nick tonight
[Music]
but the tick tock trend proved hard to
keep track of as the night went on hi
i'm kevin and this is my first drink of
the night
what drink are you on
[Music]
nine
i don't remember very 10.
maybe don't worry the eldest joe bro is
usually the responsible one right nick
and joe you're the most responsible
jonas brother i like that cat look he
had the info the vlog gives quite the
glimpse into how joe's crew spent their
night and the best part how it ended on
the birthday boy himself hey i'm joe
this is my
first drink of the night
now i can
yeah if you couldn't tell the soundtrack
to his party was kelly clarkson's since
you've been gone
[Music]
now i can
and joe's caption on the clip is pretty
perfect a few birthday drinks were had
okay so joe has some fun with the guys
but his wife sophie turner also made him
feel special on his birthday i'm so
excited about it she secured a secret
spot for joe's birthday dinner
pretty cool
uh restaurant for the birthday night
check this out first of all beautiful
sunset this is a gas station
as you can see i'm gonna enter through
here
and uh the restaurant's actually through
[Music]
as joe put in the caption wifey with the
birthday dinner win it's
amazing sophie also sent her hubby some
love on the gram sharing this intimate
shot of the two lovebirds and writing
happy birthday my love seems like joe's
33rd year is off to a great start hey
i'm joe this is my uh first drink of the
night
now i can
[Music]
you